Welcome back.
We'll now try to see what
trigonometric identity we can
come up with if we start off
with cosine of alpha plus beta.
Let's see if we can rewrite
this as another combination
of cosines and sines
of alpha and beta.
So let's get started.
And if you've already watched
the sine equivalent of this,
this proof will be pretty
similar in how we operate.
And we get a kind
of similar answer.
And something interesting is to
kind of compare the difference
between sine of alpha plus beta
and cosine of alpha plus
beta after we're done.
So just like that last proof,
let's say that this angle-- no,
that color isn't bright enough.
Let's do yellow.
Let's say that this angle
right here is alpha, and this
angle right here is beta.
Right?
We want to know cosine
of alpha plus beta.
So alpha plus beta is this
large angle right here.
Right?
So what's the cosine of that?
SOH, CAH, TOA.
So cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse.
Right?
SOH, CAH, TOA.
CAH.
So cosine is equal to
adjacent over hypotenuse.
So for this large angle,
what's the adjacent?
It's line AC.
So that equals-- line AC,
that's the adjacent.
The length of line AC over
the length of line--
what's the hypotenuse?
AB, right?
All right.
AC over AB.
Now let's see what we
can do with this.
AC-- adjacent over hypotenuse.
Now can we write AC in any
other interesting way-- a
combination of some of the
other lines on this very
fortunately designed graph?
Let's see.
Well isn't AC the same thing
as AF, this big line,
minus-- what is this?
This is a D, right?
OK.
That's a D.
Let me rewrite that as a D.
D as in dog.
There you go.
So AF minus DE.
Right?
Oh, I forgot to
draw some things.
We assume that this line is
perpendicular to that line.
We assume this line is
We assume that line is
perpendicular to that line.
Right?
And then by definition, that is
because we drew it that way.
But anyway.
So now you know that this line
is parallel to this line and
this line is perpendicular.
So we know that AF, this long
line, minus DE is equal to AC.
Does that make sense?
AF, this big line, minus
the shorter line is
the same thing as AC.
Right?
So let me write that down.
That equals AF minus DE,
all of that over AB.
And then, of course, we can
rewrite that as-- and I'm going
to switch to some different
colors-- as AF over AB.
Let me switch to maybe green.
Minus DE over AB.
So we have now AF over
AB minus DE over AB.
And those are kind of
nonsensical ratios to me.
Wouldn't it be great if
we could express it
somehow as AF over AE?
Because then we could say well
that's cosine of alpha, and
do something from there.
Well let's try.
So let's try to rewrite
this first expression.
So I'll switch back to
the purple just so you
know where this first
expression is coming from.
Let's see if we can break
this down as AF over AE
times something else.
Well, we could just
algebraically do it.
That's equivalent to AF over--
I might run out of space--
over AE times AE over AB.
And you're saying, Sal where
did you get that from?
Well, you can kind of say my
motivation was to have AF
as a ratio of over AE.
And I just set it up so that
the multiplication would cancel
out, because the AE's would
cancel out and you'd be
left with AF over AB.
Right?
So this is a reasonable
thing to do.
I hope you see.
And let me switch to the green
and do something similar.
DE over AB doesn't
make much sense.
But if I could maybe do DE over
BE, then if this angle I can
see is similar to alpha or
beta then maybe I can
make some progress.
So let's say DE over BE times--
and we'll do the same thing.
You just have to multiply
times BE over AB.
And just like in that sine
proof, and we'll do the same
thing here, let's figure out
what this angle up here is.
Right?
Because if we know that then
these ratios become useful.
So if this angle is an alpha,
then we know that this
angle right here is alpha.
Right?
Because DE-- because this
line-- is parallel to AF.
You learned that in geometry.
And if this angle is alpha we
know that this angle right here
is 90 minus alpha, because
it's complementary.
Right?
Because this whole angle
is 90 degrees, so this
is 90 minus alpha.
And since this angle 90 minus
alpha, this angle 90, and this
angle add up to 180, we could
figure out that this is alpha.
And if you don't believe me add
up alpha plus 90 plus 90 minus
alpha, and you will
get 180 degrees.
So this angle up here,
angle DBE, is alpha.
So that's very interesting.
So can we rewrite these ratios
as the sines or cosines
of alpha's or beta's?
Well, let's try.
Let me switch back to purple.
So that equals--
what is AF over AE?
Well if we look at this right
triangle, that's the adjacent
over the hypotenuse for alpha.
Right?
Adjacent over hypotenuse,
that's cosine.
So it's cosine of alpha.
And what's AE over AB?
Well, they're similar.
If we look at this big right
triangle right here that is the
adjacent over the hypotenuse
for beta, so it's
cosine of beta.
Switch my colors.
Minus DE over BE.
Well this is alpha, right?
Now there's a little smudge.
You probably can't read it.
But that was alpha.
We showed that that was alpha.
So DE is the opposite and
BE is the hypotenuse.
Opposite over hypotenuse
is sine, right?
So that's sine of alpha.
And what is BE over AB?
Look at this triangle again.
Well, for beta that is
BE is the opposite and
AB is the hypotenuse.
So opposite over
hypotenuse for beta.
So it's the sine of beta.
Times the sine of beta.
I'm running out of space.
I have to go to another line.
Pretty neat.
I'll rewrite everything in
a new and exciting color.
OK.
Let me do it in light blue.
So we now know that the cosine
of alpha plus beta is equal to
the cosine of both of them
multiplied-- so cosine of
alpha, cosine of beta-- minus
the sine of both of
them multiplied.
Minus sine of alpha
times sine of beta.
I hope you found that
as satisfying as I do.
See you in the next
presentation.